Про втрати української армії - загиблих чи поранених - командування ЗСУ поки не повідомляє.
Це один із інструментів інформаційної війни.
Але зрозуміло, що ці втрати є, і вони - чималі.
Нам вдалося поспілкуватися з пораненими українськими військовими,
які нині перебувають на лікуванні у Київській міській клінічній лікарні №8.
В ексклюзиві DW вони поділилися жахами війни, свідками яких вони стали.
Змітати все, що йому траплялося на дорозі.
Не жаліючи ні маленьких дітей, ні великих, ні пенсіонерів, нікого.
Це ніякими словами, ніякий поет, політолог… Це просто жах. Це ад.
Ми готові віддати своє життя, аби наші близькі, діти, жили у вільній незалежній державі.
Щоб тут не було ніякого руського міру.
Є багато дуже втрат, але й у нас їх не мало, ви ж самі бачите.
Менше, ніж у них, всі це знають, але все одно їм нічого не доходить.
Лізуть і лізуть, і не учать їх нічого, скільки колон уже погоріло, скільки всього,
і все одно не кінця їм не краю немає.
Я вже не знаю, що там потрібно статися в Росії, які ще їм потрібні докази того,
скільки тут їхніх солдат загинуло,
і щоб уже там якось народ піднявся, аби щоб взяли і зупинили його.
Вони не очікували того, що жартуючи до цього, у нас водії, трактористи, столяри, але всі з бойовим досвідом.
Стримати такий напрямок, це просто… це була така лінія, це словами не передати.
Я думаю, що все буде добре. Вони не очікували такого.
У них як там був розпорядок - в 6 підйом, у 7 сніданок, у 8 туалет, у 2 переодягаються і в 6 годин концерт.
Я думаю, концерт там інший, просто що з квітами.
Коли вже противник зосередив велику кількість своїх потужних вогневих засобів,
він почав просто руйнувати мирне населення, змітати все, що йому траплялося на своїй дорозі.
Не жаліючи ні маленьких дітей, ні великих, ні пенсіонерів, нікого.
Працювали ворожі гради, артилерія, авіація. Бомблять все, скрізь. Просто пекло.
На тій позиції, де я перебував, там був батюшка Московського патріархату.
Він 4 дні за нами слідкував, і тоді його спіймали СБУ, а ЗСУ взяли.
Він чітко здав наші координати, і вони вилетіли прямо на нас.
Тому що одні справді моляться за нас, щоб ми повернулися живими, щоб діти росли не сиротами,
а щоб вони росли в повноцінних родинах, а інші навпаки задають нам шкоди, зла. Я не розумію.
І ми вступили в наряд, потім ми виїхали на завдання в сторону Гостомеля.
Були там з першого числа.
Четвертого числа нам треба було покинути місце дислокації, ми виїхали,
я був водієм автобуса, вивозив людей, вивіз одну групу, потім повернувся ще раз за другою групою.
І стояли чекали групу, прилетів снаряд, бо були удари авіації, артилерії, танки, короче, лупили з усього.
Прилетів снаряд, мене поранило.
Я думаю, що в цій війні перемога лише за нами, тому що я думаю, зробити такий крок, просто руйнувати те що..
Це навіть в здоровому сенсі всього розуміння цього, бачення, уяви, це ніякими словами, ніякий поет, політолог.
Це просто жах, пекло. Це дійсно пекло.
Є позиції, нейтральні, вони просто.. де ми перебували в той час, вони просто не шкодували нічого.
Коли цією хвилею почали вибухати просто хати, і за 10 хвилин до цього бою, коли нас літаками розгромили,
просто там жили люди, я не знаю, що з ними.
Гімн України, там є такі слова, що "душу й тіло положимо за нашу свободу".
Це дуже-дуже сильні слова, які розуміє кожен українець - це слова, які відповідають дійсності.
Ми готові віддати своє життя, аби наші близькі, діти, жили у вільній незалежній державі.
Щоб тут не було ніякого руського міра…